Jennifer what is the difference between
young adult fiction versus non why a
fiction well young adult fiction is a
category it is not technically a genre
and it involves protagonists for the
most part that are ages 12 to 18 years
old the readership for a young adult is
traditionally teens but it has it has
exploded more adults or reading the
category so over 50% of the readers of
young adult fiction are now technically
adults so that's basically what
distinguishes it will be teen characters
teen characters okay and in terms of
what happens in the story the arc how
does it differ from adult readership I
don't know if the character arcs differ
so much I mean they're basically the
same kind of stories that everyone's
telling technically a lot of them maybe
are coming-of-age stories and there's
because we're dealing with that time in
a character's life which is you know
there are teen years but right now the
genre has become so expansive that it's
really tackling lots of hearted hitting
issues things like suicide things like
drug use even things like abortion or
being tackled so it's really kind of
expanded the kind of subject matter I
tend to write genre which is science
fiction so you do see a lot of science
fiction fantasy kind of writing and I
think that it's what kind of more fun
because teen readers have huge
imaginations and they love reading that
kind of stuff now what attracts you to
science fiction versus more of let's say
a personal you know a like an inner
personal story
yeah like contemporary yeah actually um
contemporary is hugely popular that's
probably the most popular thing
happening and young adult right now and
the first book I ever wrote was actually
an adult contemporary novel which did
not sell it did go on submission that is
a very typical story you'll hear from
most authors most authors don't sell
their first book it did a lot of work
for me it landed me a huge agent and I
learned a lot writing it but my heart
and my passion has always been in John
were writing I'm a huge love the Rings
fan I love Star Wars movies growing up I
read a lot of science fiction
like edgar rice burroughs Hoover at
Tarzan but I'm obsessed with his Mars
books his John Carter series so once I
started writing it I just was like wow
how did I not start writing this from
the beginning I love it so much what I
love about science fiction in particular
is kind of this idea of where our world
might be going and really grounding it
in real science real details and really
looking at something that might be
predictive but also instructive about
you know some of the pitfalls we're
falling into a lot of my books do deal
with issues like weapons nuclear
proliferation like what could happen in
the future with that so allegorically
it's pretty fascinating so yeah that's
kind of what draws me to science fiction
we talk about the ways in which the
young adult audience differs from the
adult audience not just in terms of age
but also maybe in the outcome of the
story or is it the same thing um you
know the story outcome and I think I
mean honestly I think storytelling is
storytelling I mean I think that those
of us who are writing young adult are
really striving to tell stories that are
really captivating and interesting so I
don't know that there's a lot of
difference between them aside from the
preoccupation like you're not gonna see
a young adult story that's a lot about
you know long-term marriage let's you
know you might get it as terms of you
know parent characters and maybe
relationships but you know young adult I
think though is a little bit freeing
writing it because you know with adult
fiction you tend to get locked in to
certain you know audiences and I think
the readers are a little more jaded what
I love about meeting teen readers is
that they're not jaded they are so
enthusiastic when they love something
they love it with their whole heart and
they get so excited and there's nothing
like getting kids reading so that's sort
of the difference that I see and the
adults that are reading it they're
looking for something fun and something
escapist and something that reminds them
of that time in their life when they
were teenagers so then again that tends
to be less of like the jaded kind of oh
this is like some huge literary book
where like everyone hates each other and
they're all like a ball like not that
you couldn't write that but it tends to
be
genre where it's I'm more fun to read I
think people are looking for something
that's enjoyable when these readers
approach you at book signings or
whatever are they approaching you from
the angle of enjoying the story and
feeling as if the characters are real or
are they aspiring why a author's as well
you know most of the people that come to
book festivals and book signings are
just avid readers like they're really
passionate about reading usually the
people that are turning up but these
events read voraciously so you're
talking people that consume large
quantities of books occasionally get
parents that are dragging their kids
along but mostly its readers I will get
occasionally teens that are aspiring to
write and I do work with a mentoring
program where I mentor kids and teach
writing which I love and I always get
excited whenever I meet someone that's
interested in writing or inspired to
write a big thing that happens with
young adult readers is that they end up
writing fanfiction or at least that's a
lot of times their first foray into
writing which is hugely popular online
so fanfiction would be like Harry Potter
fanfiction is huge so that would be
writing stories about the Harry Potter
characters for fun really I mean that's
really the reason to do it and there are
quite a few fan fiction authors who've
gone on to huge success like the author
that wrote the Mortal Instruments series
she started out writing Harry Potter
fanfiction Yale James who wrote Fifty
Shades of Grey
that is famously that is Twilight fan
fiction so you see a lot of that going
on Jennifer you talked about writing a
first book that did not sell and I find
that fascinating a lot of screenwriters
that watch our channel also kind of
think that their first screenplay will
sell you talked about how that was
actually probably a great stepping stone
for you although it didn't sell yeah I
can talk about it so when I first
started writing books my background was
that I had worked in the film business
for a long time so I knew a lot about
screenplays screenplay writing the
process for that I did not know much
about publishing I did not know much
about how to write a novel which is a
totally different kind of task so I kind
of said about you know teach instructing
myself I was largely self-taught I don't
have a writing degree and I learned how
to
right and ended up writing a book and
the book is adult contemporary it's a
first-person narrative which tends to be
a little more straightforward to write
it's one main character and a little bit
more of a version of myself which is
what most people write when they write
their first book and so then once I'd
finished it and gotten into shape where
I thought that it was worth showing
I started querying agents which is the
process if you would like to pursue
traditional publishing that's the
process that you go through and unlike
in the film business we're blind
querying typically does not work in
publishing it really does work book
agents you can follow the submission
guidelines on their websites the best
thing to do is to look at agents that
have sold similar books to what you're
writing and to select them based on this
being something they would also be
interested in and then you send them a
query letter so a query letter has a
specific format which is usually less
than a page and will include a little
bit about yourself a little bit about
your book and it really is what we would
call an elevator pitch in the film
business which is snappy concise
hopefully hooking and eye-catching about
what your books about and then if
they're interested you'll hear back and
they'll want to read the manuscript
hopefully so my first book which was
called all worked up and is about a
workaholic who gets sent to high-end
celebrity rehab in Malibu which is a
really fun story it's interesting I had
a lot of fans it landed me a dream agent
and agent I never thought would sign me
she insult the double Wears Prada which
was a good comp for my book at the time
and was a huge selling title and so the
book did a lot of work for me it taught
me how to write it landed me
representation I was warned at the
beginning that it would be hard to sell
because the genre which was if you I
mean this is one thing that happens in
publishing if you're a woman who writes
a book about a woman it tends to get
categorized as women's fiction
unfortunately in my opinion and so the
book that's a hard John reduce L or was
at the time so the book went on
submission but by that point I'd already
started writing what was going to be my
debut which is the thirteenth continuum
I don't think I could have written what
became my debut if I had not written
my first book which was adult
contemporary this is the 13th continuum
and it involves multiple points of view
so I was writing multiple characters
it's the first part time I wrote in
third person which is a little bit more
of a challenge to have voice in when
you're first starting to write and
involves colonies in multiple locations
so it's a pretty sweeping story they're
underwater underground in an outer space
so my first book that I wrote I think
really enabled me to then write this
book I don't think I could have written
the story if I hadn't had that first
book under my belt because I learned so
much doing it let's talk about how long
a process that was that's fascinating so
you were working in the film industry
you decided to write this book about
sort of somebody going to Celebrity
Rehab or visiting that and then from
that first time you sat down to write it
then how did how much time went by when
this was actually a finished finished
product in your hand thirteen continued
gosh I thought probably five years from
me starting to say hey I want to write
novels to landing a publishing deal
which is actually pretty fast believe it
or not yes there are Cinderella stories
of authors who sold instantly at auction
but those are pretty rare usually
authors that sell books have been
writing usually they'll have a couple
even people like David Benioff who I
think is a phenomenal writer he's a
showrunner on Game of Thrones
he wrote the 25th hour I believe the
25th hour was maybe the third book he
had written but maybe the first he sold
something like that you know and that is
a very typical story okay so you you'd
gone to you got to Harvard for film what
were you reading or what were you
looking at that helped you write the
first book that you know eventually
transcended into your why a career what
were you reading that was helping you I
always say right I always advise writers
that you shouldn't write as onra or a
category that you don't love right so if
you're someone who only reads thrillers
don't go ahead and try to write like a
romance novel you know likewise I'm not
a huge romance reader is a hugely
popular category at friends that write
it I should not be writing romance
novels because you know I'm obviously
geek for Outlander but for the most part
it's not something I read a lot of so
it's probably not what I should be
writing when I first came in to novel
writing there were two types of books I
loved to read the most and those were
what I'm gonna call female driven
narratives with female protagonists
which as I said is often categorized as
women's fiction and then big young adult
science fiction fantasy books so that's
most of what I was reading at the time
in terms of learning to write I always
advise people I just try to read really
good writing it's kind of like playing a
game of tennis you know if you play
someone worse than you you're gonna play
terribly if you play someone who's way
out of your league your game will be so
much better even if you lose and so I'm
always trying to find who are the best
writers out there right now
even if they're not anything like what
I'm writing so when I was first trying
to write really good third-person voice
I looked at Neil Gaiman a lot because I
just think he's an incredible writer and
storyteller and his books are so
engaging so things like American Gods I
looked at very closely the way he writes
character the way he writes prose and
then when did you find that you were
writing just like Neil Gaiman cuz I
heard that happened that if you focus
too much on someone that you really
enjoy then your styles yeah it comes you
can I mean everyone says that when you
first start writing you know you're
imitating like imitation is usually what
happens I'm gosh I hope I'm writing like
Neil Gaiman you know because that would
just be amazing
you know I that's part of why I think
it's also good not to saturate too much
so if there are books that are really
similar to what you're working on I
usually try not to read too much of them
at the same time because it can seep in
whereas if you're just reading someone
who's just a really strong writer like
Donna Tartt is another one I don't write
anything like her but you know then I
think just the caliber of the writing
will seep in and you'll write better but
yeah I think most of us start by kind of
imitating the things that we love I mean
the strongest influences on the 13th
continuum it's part of why the cover has
such a classic kind of sci-fi throwback
feel is that it's very influenced by
Isaac Asimov's foundation series which
is a huge influence on
it's also very influenced by Lord of the
Rings which I worked on the films for
and I'm a huge fan of but it's not an
influence in terms of the way that it's
written it's an influence in terms of
some of the ideas it's tackling I looked
at Lord of the Rings for the structure
of a trilogy because I think the way
that that story is told is just really
incredible and I really wanted to avoid
writing a series where you know the
first books great but then the second
book is disappointing or even worse the
third book is disappointing because as a
reader I get really you know upset when
I have invested and it's not gonna
deliver I really wanted to write a
trilogy and where each book is really
advancing story and building into
something big and I think Lord of the
Rings was what I looked at to see how
I'm he talking structured his story so
Jennifer what are some of the things
that a young adult author needs to know
about their readership well I think one
the most important things to know is
that your readership or it's the
category you're in main protagonist
needs to be a teenager now there is a
range for what that age is the sweet
spot is somewhere around 16 years old
if you're writing character much younger
than that your book is probably going to
be middle grade 1213 it's probably going
to skew a little younger
although the genre has opened up a
little and 16 17 18 even college seems
somewhat appropriate now in terms of the
readership I mean I think the only thing
you need to know is that there the fans
are there they're very passionate
they're looking for new material that
they can fall in love with one of the
interesting things I have encountered is
that they like to read hard books a lot
whereas I coming into it had suspected
that there would be more readers out
there I actually tend to read more on my
Kindle and a lot of the teen readers
that come to me they want hard copies
they really still love to consume hard
books and I know there's been a lot of
apocalyptic predictions about how you
know there aren't gonna be print books
anymore but based on my encounters I
don't think that's true at all and so
yeah that's really it they're really
excited they're passionate they want to
read they're big readers and I think
it's great that kids are still reading
the other thing I see a lot is that
essentially Harry Potter which is you
know JK Rowling series produced a whole
generation of readers so they've grown
up now and they're still reading and
they still love to read so she kind of
did a huge service for every other
author out there we talked about
censorship and the young adult reader I
mean when I was in my teens I was
reading Judy Blume which scene if
anything yeah it was fantastic around
here yes she is which was you know sort
of edgy for that time where is I know
that the problems present in those books
are nowhere near what's going on in
today's world so talk about censorship
whether you stay away from it whether
you I know you're talking more about
other worlds yeah things like that but
there's there's there is yeah so when
you're writing genre like science
fiction there is a certain freedom that
can come from it because you're not
writing this world so my books do have a
lot of religious elements in them but
the religions in them are not religions
that exist now so you're able to do a
critique for example of what that looks
like without may be directly offending
somebody because you're not criticizing
their choice of religion it's more
looking at a future Society likewise I
think it's easier to have diverse cast
of characters there's a reason why Star
Trek the original series was the first
show to have a black actress in a
leading role because there's something
about it that frees you from the
cultural norms of now and you're able to
envision a different kind of society in
terms of what's happened in young adult
as its exploded a young adult fiction I
believe now outsells
adult fiction which is kind of a huge
deal
adult fiction sales are down right now
young adult is still growing and so as
that's happened and as more people are
coming in and writing young adult
fiction you're seeing them tackle more
hard-hitting stories I have a friend who
read a book which is about a kid dealing
with the aftermath after his mother has
committed suicide so you're seeing a lot
of people tackling issues that are
pretty serious john green's very popular
book Fault in Our Stars
dealing with kids with cancer and what
that looks like for them so I think that
you're able to tackle a lot of pretty
serious issues in terms of censorship I
have heard stories from some of my
author friends about them encountering
some some backlash over things they've
written about I've also heard of editors
flagging cussing and cussed words which
is interesting a lot of us feel strongly
that you know teenagers talk in a
certain way and you should be able to
within reason have some of that because
I just don't think it's realistic
otherwise um you know in my books I get
to invent my own cuss word because we
have different worlds so I can kind of
get away with it and I haven't had to
tackle it the same way that other
authors who write contemporary do but
you know I just sort of think I'm just
so against censorship in all forms I
mean I think people can choose what they
want to read or don't want to read
nobody is forcing anything on anyone but
you know Judy Blume had a huge impact on
me and you know I can't Tamura Pearce's
Ilana series had a huge impact on me
it's about a girl who wants to be a
knight so she binds her chest and
dresses up like a boy but there is a
whole scene I was just reading an
interview where she gets her period she
doesn't know what it is and it's this
whole it was so groundbreaking at the
time that Tamora Pierce who's amazing
wrote it and had a huge impact on me but
now that would almost be very bland like
I don't even think it would have the
same effect but back then like like Judy
Blume like Tiger Eyes yeah it was a huge
deal so yes I think that there has been
more of an acceptance but you know I
can't say that there isn't any
censorship still is there a list of
books that are banned that's not what I
mean I know that that Judy Blume was on
some list
oh she was Harry Potter has yeah Harry
Potter's been banned there was just
recently there's a banned book stay
where we celebrate banned books yeah a
lot of books that you would think like
Harry Potter to me seems very tame that
has been banned a lot for for by
Christians for promoting sorcery or
something totally wacky in my mind to
that nature like promoting I don't know
things that are anti-christian I have no
idea but yeah the fact that they're
Harry Potter has been targeted yeah and
there's a lot of like classics
science fiction books have been targeted
a lot over the years but yeah one of my
favorite books Fahrenheit 451 is
literally about burning books and
banning books there is a whole plotline
in my book the 13th continuum where my
underwater world has fallen into a Dark
Age which is ruled by a religious
contingent so everything from before
doom was destroyed in the great purging
so we I do deal with that in my book and
what happens the fallout of when you
start to censor and eliminate
information and then what happens to
that world so yeah I am very strong
believer in access to all of these
things so but yeah I think we're still
dealing with some censorship the
internet though has also opened up a lot
it's so much easier to access things it
used to be back in the day you were
beholden to your in my case library or
maybe your local book store and I grew
up in a small southern town so I was
sort of at the mercy of what they were
willing to carry nowadays if my kid had
a Kindle you know like I would have
bankrupted my parents if I had one but
you know you can just access any book in
the world so I think it's pretty neat
his young adult fiction always told from
a first-person point of view that's
actually a great question
it is mostly most why ebooks that I see
are told from a first-person point of
view my books are not and actually do
you think that was a challenge and
selling them my books are written more
like Game of Thrones so written in third
person alternating point of views you
know but that said it is third-person
close so the third-person omniscient is
where more of like the gods perspective
third-person close is where you're still
in the character's point of view but I'm
writing it still in third person so I'm
actually hoping that we're gonna see
more of that because they think that it
gives more scope for the way you tell a
story especially in a genre like the big
science fiction types of stuff that I'm
writing but yeah I largely you see that
and I think part of that is that it is
relatable and that the voice of the
character then really shines through and
first-person stories can be great too I
mean the first book I ever wrote was in
first-person and I haven't fully ruled
out ever writing in it again because I
think it can be fun and can
be done the downside of it and you can
see I'm in series like Hunger Games I
love the first book Hunger Games is told
in a first-person narrative but then and
it's a huge world but as the books
proceeded through the trilogy and you're
still locked into one point of view I
started to get very limiting by the
third book because you had this whole
revolution going on you had all these
districts and yet you weren't able to
see that in the book whereas the film it
was able to open that up and show you
everything because the film you know has
that bigger perspective so I think it
can get limiting especially if you're
looking at telling a story over multiple
volumes so I'm hopeful that we'll see
more third-person narratives but yes you
do see a lot of the first person and
second person oh my gosh I had AI had a
writing student it was like I'm writing
in second person and I was like are you
trying to make your life really hard I'm
not to say that it hasn't ever been done
or can't be done every rule can be
broken I think especially in a short
story or something more experimental you
could probably get away with it or pull
it off writing in second person through
the scope of a novel I think would be
extraordinarily difficult part of the
reason is that and I always tell my
students this is that you know I think
it's worthwhile to always have your
reader in mind unless you just want to
write books in your bedroom and nobody
will read them and you're cool with that
but if you think you might want readers
you don't usually want to do anything
that's going to totally throw them out
of your narrative or lose them and
writing a second person can feel I would
think distracting just because it's not
typically done I mean I don't even know
that I could name a novel that's written
all in second person I think you can
maybe get away with it in parts if you
were trying to do something interesting
but you know you don't want to do
anything that's gonna really disorient
somebody now but I also always say every
rule has been broken will be broken and
there are incredible writers we're gonna
do things that I can't even fathom so
but I would say especially when you're
first starting to write don't do
anything that's reinventing the wheel or
that's going to make it too challenging
for yourself because it's already a huge
challenge to finish a novel that's like
a huge deal so I always
commence starting in first or third
person and a lot of times actually in
first person and the reason is that
developing voice is I think one of the
hardest things to do as a writer and it
is easier to do it in first person so
going back to the first story that you
wrote the first novel was that your
intention to have other readers or was
this more for you it was more personal
I've always written because I would love
to have readers I started writing
because I'm such a voracious reader and
they love nothing more than being caught
in the middle of a story where it's
keeping me up till 3:00 or 4:00 in the
morning because I can't put it down
I think it's a single best thing in the
world so I kind of wanted to write books
like that anyone to write books that
where people would stay up late at night
reading them that's probably the biggest
compliment anyone could ever give me so
I started out thinking that I did want
to publish I did want to publish
traditionally ideally and I did want
other people to read my book that said I
wrote the first one in first person
because of the voice question like I was
trying to work very hard to develop
voice as a writer and like I mentioned I
think that's easier to do in first
person I had other reasons my narrator
is also unreliable that's another good
reason to write in first person if for
some reason you have a character that is
not trustworthy my character was an
alcoholic but she didn't know it and she
wouldn't admit it so it makes her an
interesting narrator the very popular
book girl on a train uses a similar
narrative technique right where the main
character has blackouts and doesn't
remember things so she is inherently
unreliable and it makes for a very good
thriller so um so that's another reason
to choose the narrator to be a certain
tense first person puts us in her POV so
we're beholden to what she thinks but
what if what she thinks is inaccurate I
found this from going through the Barnes
& Noble blog from an article earlier
this year by Jenny kawaki I hope I'm
saying her name right six why a novels
that subvert the mean girl trope I know
you're not always writing about sort of
interpersonal relationships but this
could apply to villains so she just kind
of opens the article with she's a
cheerleader she's out to get your best
friend for no apparent reason
she's the ever-popular mean girl
or of the fictional teen universe well
we love a good mean girl and we could
substitute you know antagonists we also
wonder about her backstory why does she
hate everyone what's going on behind the
scenes so I guess it was saying how you
know even with the mean girl you have to
give them some sort of human quality
that that makes you maybe feel some
empathy or gives you some reason for why
the person is the way they are
absolutely yeah we always say
antagonists are the same as protagonists
they believe that what they're doing is
right usually I mean sure you could have
someone that's like crazy arch and you
know maybe there is no motivation but
for the most part there's a reason why
and every character should have
motivating factors they're much more
interesting that way and should have
their own reasons for doing things I
mean the best most classic example is
Star Wars Darth Vader right and they
studied very classical archetypes when
they were putting those movies together
but so Darth Vader is a hugely
frightening scary domineering antagonist
but we do find out his backstory we do
learn that no spoilers but it was Luke
and Leia's father and that he had his
own journey and art and there's three
films that addressed that so and as much
as people criticize them what I love
about episodes 1 2 & 3 is that they do
give you more insight into his character
so then when you watch the originals you
understand him more and you're starting
to see more where a character where
authors are flipping and films and
looking at the antagonist Disney's
Maleficent did that where they looked at
maleficent and did a whole movie from
her point of view and there have been
quite a few books that have done the
same thing wicked again looks at the
Wicked Witch of the West East I can't
remember but it's um you know Wizard of
Oz but it's retelling the story from her
point of view of the witch so I think
that's a really interesting exercise to
think about and I think when you're
developing out characters it's always
good to look at what are their
motivations what are the things that
have shaped them in their lives in my
story the religious contingent that runs
my underwater colony the 13th continuum
they believe that what they're doing is
right they believe that it's saving
their colony they
have you know that their religious
beliefs are important you know even if
they're destroying the world that they
live in but they believe in what they're
doing and I think that's really
important what are some of the
archetypes in ye novels not just of the
protagonist which I hear is is somehow
she's the special girl yes for some
reason and she's different from all the
others and has some type of a special
power yeah so there are a lot of tropes
that you'll see in why a for better or
worse and yes one of them is what you
were just describing which is that
they're special in some way they have
some special gift or ability or
sometimes you see that they live in a
world where everyone else has abilities
and they're the ones that don't but
there is usually something that makes
them stand out in their world in some
capacity I mean you see that a little
bit more in the sci-fi fantasy genre of
yaa
but yes that's a classic trope the love
triangle is another one and you know I
always think that people say oh this is
young adult I'm like yeah but it's also
like classic like storytelling like this
these stories Romeo and Juliet you see
that four hundred million times Romeo
and Juliet has been told and retold and
probably was taken from something even
before Shakespeare wrote Romeo and
Juliet so I think you see these things
repeat a lot Romeo and Juliet does pop
up a lot in Y a right star-crossed
lovers right Twilight is basically Romeo
and Juliet with vampires there's a book
called a worm I think it's called warm
bodies that is Romeo and Juliet was on
these and it was made into a film as
well so you see a lot of that kind of
stuff a lot of times you'll also see so
these are coming-of-age story so usually
they're being oppressed in some way it
could be by parents or adults that rule
the world it could be by some greater
antagonist but usually they're fighting
the system or they're fighting against
something about their world that isn't
fair let's talk about other archetypes
so you have sort of the jock oh yeah the
hot jock who maybe seems like the dream
guy but then you have like the loner guy
that she's not supposed to be with
because her friends don't approve but
she really likes the frenemy
the nerdy girl that's the sidekick can
we talk about some of the archetypes
yeah that's pretty typical I mean the
nerdy girl I mean Hermione from Harry
Potter's your classic version of that
you know I think in terms of jock and
already guy yeah you're gonna definitely
still see that the Netflix show stranger
things which was really fantastic a
hundred percent does that but they do do
a few things to subvert some of that
we're you know I think it's interesting
to do turns with some of those jockey
characters where maybe they see the
light come around a little you know and
those stories yeah the high school the
hierarchy of school that's gonna be very
prevalent across all these books
including the ones that aren't even in
our world like you know even things like
Harry Potter which I know skewed younger
to start by moved into ye territory or
even things like Twilight there's always
a high school element in the hierarchy
of the society so yeah you see all of
that as well
you know but I think it's kind of fun to
read those things and again they're
coming from somewhere which is the real
world you know like if we've all been to
high school like I feel like we've all
had these experiences right so it sounds
like there's either the decision to
leave the group or the decision to join
the group and and will they accept them
it's either reverse in one of those two
ways and as an adult always an oppressor
no not always usually they'll be yeah I
mean you'll usually have also characters
that are like you know nice good adult
characters or at least I always try to
write them into my book and one of the
things I did in my my series is that I
did give point of views to adult
characters and that was actually one of
the things that also I think made the
book a challenge right off the bat to
sell even though we found a great
publisher and I did get a great book
deal out of it but in the beginning I
got feedback like you have adult points
of view in this book like how is this
why a and I'm like one of the main
characters are teens but yes there are
adults that live in this world and I
wanted to show also some of that
perspective and some of the adults are
the antagonists in the case of the first
book it's the leader of the religious
contingent who kind of governs their
world gets some chapters where we get to
see sort of their thoughts
process and what's happening on their
end of the story and then otherwise
we're going between Myra who is a 16
year old engineering apprentice in the
underwater world and a outer space
colony where our main character is arrow
who is a 16 year old soldier and their
military society and so the stories told
back and forth between them and then as
the book series progressives my second
book comes out in November the story
opens up a lot we add more points of
view so we start to track more
characters and some of those are adults
we pick up an underwater character who
is an adult character and he carries
through so I think it's fun to write a
variety of different perspectives but
now some of the adult characters are
always you know I hope going to be
positive too you know but you will say
young adult it is mostly focused on the
kids and it is gonna be mostly focused
on the teen characters so with young
adult fiction is one of the tests that
it should be enjoyable to adults that if
it's not then maybe a young adult
readership would be bored because it's
not sophisticated enough that's a really
great question I would say that kids
tend to read up which means that you
know whatever the age range that we
specify for these books I find they tend
to read up like I was reading Stephen
King and Anne Rice when I was in Middle
School in high school but I probably
started out reading things like Judy
Blume and things that skewed a little
bit younger so yeah I think it does need
to have a certain level of
sophistication to hold a teen audience
now if it skews too old I mean my books
are considered more crossover for some
of the reasons I was talking about that
I have some adult points of view that it
is a third-person multiple point of view
story so when I was originally trying to
sell it we got a lot of feedback like
this is crossover we don't know how to
market it and I was like isn't that a
good problem like what isn't it better
if it appeals to both teens and adults
but so the publishing industry I think
has been a little slow to catch up to
this idea that a lot of adults are
reading young adult and that teen meters
do you tend to read up if I think
they're a little behind and
understanding that but
I think that it's a real benefit if the
book is a little more sophisticated if
it is appealing both to teens and adults
but yeah I think you need to keep their
attention another thing that I think is
important which we've really tried to do
with my series is to put the books out
in a relatively quick timeframe because
also readers they will grow out of
reading something so if you have
multiple years between books coming out
I think you're doing yourself a
disservice because you know by the time
the second book comes out they're
already in college right and then the
third book who knows so we're trying to
do six months apart on my trilogy
because I think that makes a lot of
sense is there a focus group that you're
running the let's say semi edited
version through oh I don't really have a
focus group I mean I think that when you
first start writing a lot of authors
have critique partners which are really
important to the process which would be
trusted readers that you trust to give
feedback on your manuscript I have
another author that I trade books with
and he writes stuff totally different
from me it's a typically these days it's
a nonfiction World War two Nazi books
you know so they're totally different
but he's really smart and we trade reads
now that I have a publishing deal and I
have a big agent team I don't do that as
much and I don't really have the time so
my team is the people who are reading
and giving feedback or my agent and my
editors at my publishing house so and I
read this point I'm really tailoring the
books to them because that's who's
really going to be distributing my book
and then I'm also at this point trying
to keep a consistency in the story and I
kind of know where I am and how I'm
writing it so I'm not at a place where I
need feedback so much on how I'm writing
if that makes sense in the beginning a
lot of it is trying to improve your
craft I'm at a point now where I'm just
trying to tell the best stories that I
can because I you know I already have a
style that I've developed in terms of
how I write so but I am looking forward
to getting back to writing something
different and new and I'm sure I'll be
using
critique partners on that once I start
writing my next book let's take the
hypothetical author that's just written
their first novel and now they're
looking for an agent mm-hmm what steps
should they take
how committed to that book should they
be how free should they be to say maybe
this isn't the one yeah I mean I think
you always I mean I think it's always
worth at the time when you write your
first book you'll be so attached to it
and so in love with it that it will be
heartbreaking if you don't get agented
or if it doesn't sell even though that's
really typical my advice is always once
you start the querying process is to
start writing your next book so you have
something else that you're focused on
and you know that it's not the end of
the road and a lot of times it might
take an author of several books before
they find an agent that is not uncommon
but things I really recommend are
workshopping a lot taking classes like
the ones I teach at the writing pad
which have a workshop component or I I
work shop the book that I sold the
thirteenth continuum with Meg Wolitzer
who's one of my favorite authors um I
also work shopped with Victor Laval
who's another one my favorite authors
and I would go to conferences and try to
meet people and it just improved my
writing for the querying process it
really is finding the agents that you
think are the best fit for your material
who are open to submissions and then
really following their guidelines
writing a great query letter spending a
lot of time getting that perfect and
then guess going through the process
publishing moves very slowly so it can
be months and months and months process
of even just hearing back from one
person and then once you're going on
submission it can also be months and
months and months and months because
they get inundated with so much material
so I think that the best way to handle
it is to then also be working on
something for yourself otherwise so you
have something ready to go if an agent
comes back to you and says hey I really
like your book but I'm not sure I can
sell this but I'd love to see what you
do next so then you have something to
say hey I'm going to be doing this next
and you can come back to them so for the
query letter did you have a template
that you found that you just kind of
change the names and dates and things
like that kinetic scent I mean there is
there are good websites online that will
show the format so the format is
something you really want to follow and
sticks to although I you know I don't
think you can really do just like
changing things because a lot of it is
like writing that
really hooky elevator pitch you know
making sure you have a great bio ready
to go you know that's you know concise
and descriptive because you know when
they're looking at your query letter
that's the first example of can you
write well and so your query letter
really needs to be written well and I
also think ideally in a tone that really
reflects your book which is to say
especially the synopsis like you know if
your book is really kind of snappy and
witty then your synopsis probably should
be somewhat in the same vein to convey
that and then in terms of personalizing
it I think it really is worthwhile when
you're querying agents to personalize to
them which is to show some knowledge
about what books they've represented
what types of genres they like if you
were a big fan like my agent had sold
The Devil Wears Prada which I absolutely
loved you know let them know that you
loved this book and that this you're
coming to them because you've been you
know you know who they are you know who
their agency is I think if you
personalize and even better if you have
a personal connection or some way like
you've been at a conference where they
spoke even it doesn't even have to be
that you knew them but I saw you on X
panel at the AWP conference and I was
really impressed and so I am coming to
you so I think that those things all
helped a lot but a lot of it is it's
just like an editor friend of mine who
used to work at HarperCollins she told
me in the beginning she's like it's like
dating she's like you're gonna go on a
lot of dates and I think that's really
accurate because you really are looking
for the right fit with an agent being on
a gentle is actually better than being
with a bad agent and it doesn't seem
like that would be the case but it is
someone who isn't a good fit for you or
isn't doing your work justice
um can actually do more damage then just
on even having an agent so I just think
it's very important to make sure that it
is the right fit for your material for
you because they really need to be your
cheerleader like they really are the
person that's going to be helping you
through the crazy process of trying to
find a publisher and ideally I think
also to find someone who's in it for the
long haul who's gonna stay with you when
your first book doesn't sell because
that's so common who's gonna be there
for your next book and he will still
represent you when you switch genres and
back and say hey I'm writing Wi-Fi now
can we still do this I was very lucky
that my agent has been amazing and it's
really stuck by me through the whole
process you know and she's responsive
like responds to my emails right away I
know a lot of people will struggle with
that sometimes if your agent is not
getting back to you yeah I think that's
a real problem so you know I think it's
really important to try to find the
right person can you give some other
hypotheticals of how being sort of a
Giunta might be better than being with
the wrong parent yeah there are a bunch
of different ways um when I used to go
and speak either meet with or speak with
some pretty well-known authors and they
used to say things like you know I'm so
glad that my first book didn't sell in
retrospect and it's really hard to see
that at the time because it will be
heartbreaking but I was hanging out with
and radio booths who wrote the House of
Sand and Fog which is a best-selling
book he's been on Oprah and his dad was
like the biggest short story author ever
so the guy had connections but I believe
I asked him the first book that you sold
how many of you Britain and I think he
said three or four it was quite a few
and this is a guy who actually had a
publishing connections and you know a
writing degree and all those fancy
things um and the thing about it is that
you know when you're first writing
you're really developing your craft and
you get better so a lot of times maybe
the first thing you write isn't quite in
the sweet spot of what you're supposed
to be writing and a lot of times you'll
look back and be like oh wow I really
was undeveloped it really is better that
this is the stage where I sold a book
and began off there is a little
different from some other creative
professions because you don't really age
out of it to the same degree I mean sure
you know publishing loves the young 22
year old who has a hit book like
Veronica Roth who wrote divergent yeah
they love that narrative but a lot of
times authors are gonna write their best
work when they get older
30 40 50 60 I mean Frank McCourt here at
Angela's Ashes I think you wrote that
and when he's 50 or 60 and it's one of
my favorite memoirs of all time a lot of
my favorite authors who are still
producing work are not young people
Ursula Le Guin alright like okay like
Gwen's amazing I'm obsessed with Stephen
King I think he's a genius
I still read all of his books and he's
still publishing a ton I still read Anne
Rice but then there's other people I
know Philip Roth retired but only
recently I mean he was writing books up
until a couple years ago so and I think
a lot of times they're producing their
best work like Cormac McCarthy I think
is writing some of his best books within
the last 10 years and he is not a young
man so I think that we develop over the
course of our writing careers and I like
to look at it as you know I hope to
write many many many books and I hope to
get better as I do so so really kind of
cultivating that writing style versus
voice mmm what are the differences yeah
well I always talk well I always talk
what is the difference between character
and voice so a character is someone in a
story and they're going to have a voice
which is going to be a way that they
talk but then the overarching voice of a
story is you know more about the way
that it's told like the style and the
voice in terms of the writing and
sometimes that is also the character's
voice especially if you're writing in
first person or a 3rd person close
because you're trying to encapsulate
what they see and feel and then what was
the other thing you asked about oh yeah
so writing style yeah they kind of
overlap a little bit I mean the style of
writing and the voice voice is really
trying to capture the feeling of the the
narrator's voice or the characters voice
or the way the story is told the style
of it I guess would be more like the way
that you're writing the book but there's
a lot of overlap between all three of
those areas but when you pick up a book
that has really strong voice you know
you're usually hearing the character and
hearing the world and every book exists
within its own world even books that
aren't specifically sci-fi/fantasy
you're still crafting a world even if
it's something like a thriller it has a
feel and an internal logic to the world
and it's not necessarily the real world
even if it is a contemporary story
something like gone girl exists in its
own world I don't think those people
exist in the real world those characters
to me are very unrealistic in a lot of
respects but in the world of that story
they're all like that and so I don't
think that that's like a real world
thing even though it takes place here
and now but there is a specific way that
she writes her stories
that you know she transports you into
them hooking in the reader from the
beginning how is I'm sure that's going
to vary especially within the why a
world and the different genres that
there are whether it's science fiction
whether its steampunk whatever yeah we
have seen Punk of fun yeah I mean I
think hooking the reader just so
important and regardless of what you're
writing I just think you know for me if
I'm not really feeling about 50 and I
don't put a lot of books down but 1500
pages is a long time and if I'm not
feeling it and you'd be surprised how
many books I think and don't really work
on that level I might not finish it and
especially when you're dealing with more
commercial genres it becomes even more
important younger readers I think it
becomes even more important that said I
don't think you need to rush or
sacrifice the storytelling to make it so
hooky in a certain respect like I
personally wouldn't want to do that but
I think getting into the story right
away having something exciting happen in
the beginning in my book I chose to
write a prologue that showed kind of
what happened before when the surface of
the earth was destroyed so I told it
from if you can imagine the president's
daughter's point of view as they're
evacuating the White House so young girl
being evacuated and I cuz I did that and
for a couple reasons but one was I
wanted to have something really exciting
and really relatable that happened right
off the bat because I think that that
will cook you in and make you want to
read more but there's other ways to hook
somebody like having a great character
I'm having central mystery is something
I teach about a lot which is it doesn't
mean that it has to obviously there's a
mystery genre where the whole story is
crafted around a mystery but that said
you can have a story that has smaller
mysteries that are revealed in the
beginning of a book a good example is in
The Hunger Games they talk about the
reaping which is the big thing that
happens right away in The Hunger Games
but they say the word the reaping seven
or eight times before they finally tell
you what it is and you find out fairly
early in the story but still you're kind
of reading like oh what is this what is
this thing that's happening what is this
big event so I think that's another way
to kind of get somebody interested and
trying to figure out what's going on too
much conflict too little conflict do ye
readers want more conflict than maybe
adult readers I think you have more
leeway to do some bigger kind of more
epic sweeping sorts of things like what
you would see in a Star Wars movie for
example um you know too little conflict
in any story or too little tension and
the story is going to be really boring
and nobody's going to be interested I
think you need to have conflict and
tension almost if not in every scene of
your book pretty much in every scene
even scenes that are character driven I
always think you want to look for how
can you ramp up the tension in that even
if it's just a dialogue exchange you try
to have moments that are ratcheting up
the tension so a good example of that is
something like in the beginning of the
shining the movie I also loved the book
but the film there's a scene where it's
the mom talking to Child Protective
Services so you're learning information
about the fact that the father may have
been abusive toward to the son but it's
just a dialogue scene but the whole time
she's smoking a cigarette and the ash
just gets longer and longer and you're
like oh my god ash your cigarette you
get so tense for her you're like that's
gonna fall all over you and she doesn't
and it just somehow is this genius way
of just keeping tension so there's
always little things you can look at in
a scene to kind of keep the tension
going and then obviously there's big
conflict scenes where there's a fight or
actually something major happening or a
major obstacle but I think throughout a
story that's what keeps you reading and
people even be like oh it's getting
worse it's getting so much worse for
these characters and you know or even
like a book series like Game of Thrones
you're like oh my god things are still
happening and happening but it's like
that's what keeps the story going you
know a story without conflict is a
really boring story
I think Kurt Vonnegut famously said make
great characters and then make bad
things happen to them well if a book is
not part of a series let's suppose it's
just going to be a standalone book is
the protagonist always victorious in the
end no and I think even in a and you see
that a lot especially on my books
considered just hope Ian you see that a
lot in dystopian series where a lot of
times they're not victorious and I
always when I teach structure I talk
about that where you know there's going
to be
at the end of a story where a character
makes a decision they need to make a
choice that really reveals their moral
caliber but that doesn't mean that the
choice they make has to be the right one
a good example is Romeo and Juliet right
Romeo does make a choice at the end and
it is a terrible choice it ends
tragically for him he made the wrong
decision
so no it doesn't always have to result
in a happy ending and I think some of
the greatest stories sometimes don't
that said I think if you are gonna go
for really kind of like all the negative
ending but an ending where the
protagonist is not victorious it makes
your job so much harder in a lot of ways
I think you really need to pull that off
because your readers are probably going
to be a little bit mad at you to a
certain extent so I think it needs to
have a compelling reason to have that
sort of ending or you know a compelling
reason why you wanted to do that for
your story because we've all been there
or we've seen something with it with an
ending that we were like wow that was
really dark and like sometimes I love it
and even in films where you know
classically a lot of that is focus group
tested out of the film but films like I
am Legend or the 3rd Terminator film
where like something really dark happens
at the end but then it's awesome and of
course if you get into more like horror
movies and things like that then it's
almost expected because a lot of times
in those the antagonists becomes the
protagonist so when we're watching
Nightmare announced rate right okay
originally yeah maybe we're rooting for
Johnny Depp in the teens but the certain
point Freddy is the who we're rooting
for at a certain point you're showing up
at these films to see Michael Myers or
you know Leatherface or whoever pinhead
I'm a huge Hellraiser fan but you're
showing up for them more so almost in
who are the classic protagonists and you
kind of want to see them when in the end
and boy would you be upset if Freddy was
dead at the end
I know Freddy's dead as a movie but he's
not really dead the ideal length of a
why a novel word count what's the
typical length and then if you stretch
it what's to be expected yeah that's
actually a great question and that's
something I obsessed about when I was
writing because I write long books I
tend to always write very
so I know other people struggle with
writing shorter and their word counts
being low I would say the sweet spot at
least in my opinion is somewhere between
seventy five thousand and eighty five
thousand words for contemporary yaa
which would be a story told in the here
and now you will see books that are
shorter so I think you get away with
even sixty five thousand words or
obviously longer than that if you start
to go above a hundred thousand words in
my book definitely does and they do the
first book I believe is somewhere in the
hundred and five thousand word range
which is comparable to something like
Hunger Games and as the series
progresses where you will get more
leeway in word count they do span
upwards I'm looking at closer to one
hundred twenty thousand on the third
book but like I said when you're doing
big world building genre books sci-fi
fantasy you do get more leeway on word
count regardless of genre so you can get
away with something that is over a
hundred thousand words if you've never
sold a book before and you're going on
submission I would caution you against
I'm doing anything that's too much
longer than 100 105 thousand because
that's a pretty hefty book but that said
I mean everyone you know has sold things
that you know are of different lengths
and you know I always think that the
word count should justify be justified
by the story so I did learn that when
you write multiple POVs that will
pollute balloon your word count so um
that's why Game of Thrones is so long I
have a lot of empathy for george RR
martin but there's a reason why his
books are spanning over a thousand pages
you know because once he starts telling
all those multiple stories it really is
gonna expand it so but yeah but so the
sweet spot of word count is gonna be
somewhere in those ranges let's talk
about the new author that has an agent
and now has landed a publishing deal
what should they expect what should they
maybe not hold so tightly be very
flexible with and maybe things that they
should fight for yeah i mean i think
that that's going to vary a little bit
from author to author and publishing
house to publishing house I know people
have had horror stories and terrible
experiences and I know people have had
great ones I've actually had a fantastic
experience
publishing house and going into it I
wasn't sure because I had heard so many
stories from other authors that weren't
always positive so I didn't really know
what to expect in terms of what to hold
on to and what not to I you know I
always try not to be too precious about
my work that I can't take notes from an
editor and I just always try to remember
that they're on your team and they're
trying to make your work better of
course I think it's important also to
hold fast to things that are really
important to you so if someone's trying
to alter something about your story that
it just goes against what you really
believe you know you can fight for that
but ideally you're getting into bed with
an editor that really gets your work I
think some of the problems come from
getting into bed with a publishing house
or an editor where they want you to be
something different than what you see
for yourself and for your book so being
on the same page right off the bat will
help in terms of being not too precious
well I mean cover design is a big one I
was lucky enough that my agent got me
approval which I don't think is that
common always so I had some control over
the process but I also didn't have to
use it cuz I loved the book cover let's
see it okay yeah I loved it all right
off the bat it was exactly it was so
beautiful is exactly something so I
didn't actually have to use my approval
but you know and I've heard you even
think stories like that Barnes & Noble
can get publishers to change book covers
to what they want which is kind of wild
that they have that much control
sometimes and I know people sometimes
are frustrated by that in terms of what
to be Precious about or not I think when
you're coming into marketing and release
I think that you know there's gonna be
some reviews that probably aren't going
to be uniformly positive and that can be
from a magazine or a trade publication
or a blogger it can also just be from a
random reader on Goodreads and I think
sometimes you know maybe not taking
those seriously just understanding that
different readers are gonna like books
or not like books and that isn't a
reflection on the quality of what you
did you know not every book is for every
reader and I think that you just kind of
being okay with that you know and not
because you know it's very easy to feel
bad or get hung up on negative reviews
and you know you just don't know what
was going through the reviewers mind
maybe they just don't like books that
are in that
maybe who who even knows so just kind of
not taking any of that stuff too
seriously
but I do advocate authors take an active
role in marketing their books I think
too many authors will sign a deal and
then kind of sit back and expect their
publishing house to do everything and
the truth is that they're stretched very
thin they have so many titles a lot of
times if you're a new author and your
book isn't the big superstar book that
they're promoting that time you might
not get a lot of resources or attention
so then it becomes your job to really
kind of advocate and really kind of work
for your book so can we go into some of
the more technical parts of selling the
book yeah so basically once you go on
submission and this is applying to
having an agent and approaching
traditional publishing houses you know
your agent is going to be sending your
book to different editors that they've
identified that they think the book
could be appropriate for so then it's
kind of a lot of hurry up and wait like
the book goes out you know and then
maybe you're looking in your book sells
at auction for a bazillion dollars and
you're set but for most books it's going
to take a number of months for those
editors who are getting so many
submissions to even get back to you and
then also it's not when I first went
into it I was like oh it's whether or
not they you know you wrote a great book
that is not what has to do with whether
your book sells writing a great book is
what gets you through those door steps
and gets you agent it like you've gone
through the hurdles you wrote a great
book but now it's a business so it's
about you know what is that publishing
house looking for for their list what do
they think is selling what do they think
they can mark it and that has nothing to
do with the quality of your book that
has everything to do with the business
which you can't predict or control so
once that process happens ideally you're
gonna get an offer or multiple offers
and you're gonna sell your book so once
that happens in my case I had a three
book deal for the series so you have
deadlines for the subsequent books and
then you basically send off your
manuscript that manuscript goes to your
editor your editor then is going to go
through a revision process with you in
my case I did not have to do a lot of
developmental edits but that could be an
example where there are bigger things in
the story that they
you to address or change and then after
that you'll go through a line edit which
is where your editor will mark up your
draft line by line with notes and I
always try to think oh this makes the
book a lot better I love having a lot of
eyes on my material so that's a whole
other path and then after line edit so
you go to copy edit and copy edits are
Grammer things also tracking you know if
like you know character suddenly changes
names halfway for your book which really
shouldn't happen ideally you don't have
that but you know that kind of stuff
looking at doesn't do things make sense
so kind of more of a technical pass and
then after that the book gets set into a
typeset which is what it will look like
on the page and then even then you can
go through it and still make adjustments
and changes but each time it's less and
less and more specific and more specific
so there are a lot of passes just on the
editorial aspect I'm getting your book
ready for publication presenting oneself
as an author do's and dont's BIOS how
much do you engage with your readership
um yeah I mean that's all really good
questions I mean I think it's so
thrilling to have readers I love having
readers usually when you're writing for
so long you're like oh my god I'm
writing these weird stories and like
nobody else knows what they are and I'm
obsessed with them and so when it starts
got in the world and you people actually
know about your characters I want to
talk to you I think it's the best thing
in the world so I tend to engage as much
as I can I think now it's really
important to have a digital component to
everything that you do so as a new
author you have to have a website I
swear you have to have a great website
and ideally on that some contact
information obviously if you become so
popular that's overwhelming that's
another thing to address but usually
most of us it's not overwhelming to have
be reachable be accessible so having a
great website having a great bio I think
is incredibly important because you end
up using that so much for so many things
you know setting up your Amazon page
setting up your Goodreads author page
Facebook Facebook page Twitter Instagram
like you kind of have to decide how many
different outlets you really think you
can handle but you know it's important
to have
a presence on a lot of these places and
then also I think that helps with
finding a community of other authors
that are writing things similar to yours
there are a lot of incredible Facebook
groups that I'm in that have been just
so important to what I do so I think
having that digital presence is really
important having a great summary of your
book is really important that's
something that will go to your agent
originally when they go on submission
it's something that will go to your
publishing house to help them even with
the back cover copy sometimes so it's
really important to have all those
things oh and a good headshot you'd be
surprised how much because you need that
for the book itself but then also for
your website and for like a hundred
things speaking engagements panels so
having a headshot actually it's really
important writing every day this is a
myth or a must for an author I think
it's kind of a must I mean I think that
you know we go through different periods
where we rank you baiting ideas or
working on ideas the thing I think about
with having a regular writing practice
is that it gets you into the mode of
producing pages all the time and then I
think also for me when I work into a
story I'm like in the world of the story
and I'm always kind of walking around a
little bit in that world and so it's a
much more seamless process when I go to
sit down to work if I take a few days
off and then go back it takes time to
work back into the story for me so I
lose time just by having being out of it
and then coming back in so I think
writing every day will help with that
because it keeps you in the story and
keeps you moving through it I also
always say you know it's amazing how in
the amount of time you spend writing you
actually equals more pages it's not like
people think there's some crazy formula
to it I'm like no it really is time in
equals time out you know and yeah you
know some days are gonna be better
writing days than others so it's not to
say that every day you sit down you're
gonna have this amazing output some
writers have word counts that they like
to do per day I have never done that for
myself a lot of times it's more just
giving yourself permission to write what
we call my little say the crappy first
draft or the bad first draft and so you
kind of free yourself from the
perfectionism that sometimes it is
really what writer's block is writers
lock is really
feeling the perfectionism and thinking
that writing will be not as good as what
you want it to be and once the fear of
not writing overwhelms that then that's
usually when we start writing so giving
yourself permission to write something
that isn't as good as you really want it
to be on the first pass and then a lot
of times sitting down saying you know
it's okay you can write a paragraph
that's okay and then usually once I
write a paragraph I'll be in it and be
writing away but saying like you know
cuz if you sit down you're like I have
to write 10 pages that can get
overwhelming in and of itself because
that's a lot of pages so just kind of
like being a little bit flexible in how
much you're really putting out but yeah
I would say writing everyday is it's
somewhat important and where do you
write where'd you do your best writing
um you know I started out where I would
write at home most of the time but now I
kind of call it the great coffee shop
rotation which is to say I move around
to a lot of different coffee shops but I
might have two shifts where one is a
coffee shop and then I come home and
work more especially when I'm under a
very crazy deadline like I am right now
and there's other writers that I know
and a lot of these coffee shops that
becomes kind of a community you know and
some of them are screenwriters or doing
different types of things so you know I
have my friends that I see and it's a
little bit like going to an office you
know with being home a lot which you
know some people do do their best work
at home it can get a little bit where
you get distracted because it's like the
hundred things you need to do like
unload the dishwasher make the bed like
do this do that and so leaving the house
kind of gets you away from all of that
plus coffee good coffee so um so that's
kind of where I kind of do it now and
then I do things like my parents live in
Virginia in the country so sometimes
I'll go out there for a couple weeks and
and take it like a working kind of
retreat I also try to go in a lot of
workshops and residency so I did one in
Tuscany last year and I'm actually going
to Provence to work with some writers
and Julia Child's old house it's cooking
and writing retreat but um I find that
sometimes the travel and then being
around other authors is really conducive
to creativity plus you're getting
feedback and you're getting you know
workshopping so that aspect is nice too
so I always try to do stuff like that
and how do you write on a laptop do you
use just a legal pad
oh yeah I write on a laptop I for sure
and I use word but I want to learn
Scrivener even though I hear there's a
learning curve and I'm scared Scrivener
is software that a lot of authors swear
by and use and then I write on a laptop
but I do have a little notebook I carry
well scribble down ideas also I mean
depends on what stage of the writing I'm
in but when I'm drafting a story I'll
have a lot of ideas that pop up in the
middle of the night or in the shower or
when I'm walking so I end up emailing
myself like a lot of notes like or even
sometimes I'll sketch out whole scenes
on my cell phone when especially if I'm
not at home or with my computer just
like oh here's what I'm thinking and be
like through and then so I'll email that
to myself and then I'll have it because
you know inspiration pops up at all
hours of the day in the night so your
debut novel the thirteenth continuum
sold and then at some point you have now
a three-book deal which is that was the
first book of the three and now it's
being turned into a film yeah we're
working on that so my background is that
I used to work in film and TV
development and so actually before I
even sold it to a publisher I had
producers that were working on it it's
always had a lot of interest from a lot
of producers the first set of producers
once to do it for TV and we're sort of
working with them but a certain point
they weren't being super effective and
we kind of felt more like going in the
film direction so I switched to a
different producer and she's been great
and we're working on packaging it into a
film
so they've a deal at Warner Brothers and
then right now we're looking at writers
and directors because in the environment
of right now it really helps to have a
package and to go in with a package and
there are a couple reasons why I think
that's good but one of them is that I
don't want to rush and do a bad version
of the film I've worked enough in
Hollywood and worked on enough big book
adaptations like Lord of the Rings and
The Golden Compass that I know it really
matters how you put it together and then
also it's one thing just option a book
you can do that but then there's
something we call development hell where
it just kind of gets stuck and never it
gets made so the more you have attached
and the more you go in with the more
likely it is that you're going to
actually be able to make the film
because I don't want to just option it
and have it sit and there are so many
fabulous books and fabulously popular
books that have never been made that's
sold for a lot of money that studios
have things like Justin Kernan's the
passage is a good example and it just
hasn't been made it's been years and
years so I kind of want to do it in a
way that really does justice so I'm not
really in a rush I want to do it right
so the second book is coming out
November 1st yes and tell me the title
it's called return of the continuance
okay and then you have the third book
which you're finishing up now as we
speak
I'm finishing it up now and that will
come out in probably end of May next
year and it's called the United
Continuum's so that's the other thing
that's nice about a series is that with
each book as an opportunity and really
kind of drives attention and drives
readership and there's a whole marketing
effort so it's kind of nice because you
know you don't have one book and that
kind of gets forgotten or left behind
each time you're going out with a new
book it's bringing them all kind of
together and you see a lot of times
these things build over time readership
builds popularity builds and we can all
cite really famous series where they
weren't big until later there's a great
piece by the author he wrote Percy
Jackson that series which were made into
films and I think he said it was two
full years after the first book came out
was when they first had an inkling that
it was going to be a huge huge hit but
for two years it wasn't selling much and
they weren't sure he was doing signings
like nobody was showing up but it was a
building process like they really
believed in it and they really worked
hard so it can take time and the other
thing to remember with a book and I'm
sort of experiencing this now is that
it's not like a film where you know
everyone will go opening-day and see it
and then be talking to their friends
like you know even if people buy it
close to when it comes out it might not
get read instantly a lot of us and this
includes me have a ton of books in our
queue and a lot of things it doesn't
mean we're not going to read it but it
might be a month or two later that I
find
we do and so you start to see that even
a couple months after it's been out
people are finally like oh my gosh I
finally read this and you start to hear
and I'll send more people you start to
hear so it's like not like an opening
day phenomenon and the other cool thing
about books as they exist and once
they're in the world they're in the
world a long time so you started to see
them popping up in libraries and popping
up that's the nice thing about young
adult is that you know libraries are
huge for us
schools are huge for us school libraries
are huge for us and there's also a lot
of kids that can't really afford or
don't have the budgets to buy a lot of
books so they're waiting to get them
from their library which i think is
fantastic I was that kid so I totally
understand that when you first began
writing the 13th continuum was it in
your mind to turn this into a film to
turn this into a series or did this come
in incremental steps yeah it was in my
mind from the beginning for sure that it
had to be a trilogy I'm the story once
it started to take shape in my mind was
so epic and sweeping and involved
multiple different environments that I
kind of felt strongly that I needed to
be a series and also that I wanted to
play the long game a little bit with the
series which means that certain reveals
don't happen even till second or third
book which is a little bit risky
actually because it's harder to land a
deal for multiple books all at once
also my main protagonist like they kind
of aren't really meeting in person until
the second book and quite into it so
that that was a big risk I took but I
took it because I really believed in the
story I was telling in terms of the film
aspect I do write very visually and I do
write in a way that is pretty adaptable
and this series in particular because
it's big world building science fiction
with teen protagonists Hollywood has
changed a lot especially even since I
started working in it and so the types
of films they make are become more
narrow but this slots right into what
they still make which is the big genre
films that could be a temple so that's
one of the reasons why we feel that this
could be appropriate for film even
though you know TV is still on the table
because TV is such a rich landscape
right now and lots of books are being
adapted into television show
so you're seeing kind of this real shift
and where people are viewing and
consuming content we're kind of in a
very changing time I call it the wild
wild west of media publishing so we'll
see what comes to pass how much did you
working in film previously you know
coming to LA having that as your degree
help in seeing the bigger picture that
if you had really started out with say
an MFA and writing or something maybe
would have made it more myopic yeah it
would I mean I think MFA and I went back
and forth a lot about whether or not I
needed one at a certain point in my life
and they're very expensive typically yes
there are some that are funded those are
incredibly difficult to get into but for
the most part you're gonna be going into
debt
you know most authors do and then being
an author isn't typically that lucrative
for a variety of reasons so you kind of
end up in a hole and you know a lot of
people MFA's end up teaching that kind
of ends up being what their job is and
if you teach too much it can be hard to
write your own work the other thing that
happens with MFA is they they largely
teach to short story which not many
people read short stories is not and
that's why you see a lot of people
coming out as programs might publish a
short story collection right off the bat
if they're lucky and then also they tend
not to be so welcoming to young adult
writers and also to people who write
genre like myself there are exceptions
to that Hollins College has a great
program for children's writers I believe
Vermont College of Fine Arts has a great
program but for the most part we are not
really going to be getting into the Iowa
Writers Workshop so it's a little bit of
a different process but I think also not
having that I think some of MFA it's a
little intimidating they come out of
school and they're like oh my gosh I
have to write like you know like these
great of these great authors and you
know as opposed to just really
developing what you want to write in
your story the film background was
interesting because I think it did shape
how I consume and understand stories and
also I write very structurally and very
visually because a lot of my job was
working on screenplays with writers and
I worked on a lot to add up patients and
screenplays are incredibly structural
first act second act
Point Break third-act and they really
have to slot into a certain page count
to even really be considered so I really
kind of look at structure a lot when I'm
writing a novel and I think about that a
lot and I think you know there is a lot
of translation between the way these
stories are told what do you plan is the
process once you've finished the third
book which will be in May of next year
you're looking for a writer director yes
a writer and/or director I mean
sometimes a writer director in my
experience working in development um
having a director who has a vision for
how they want to translate something to
screen is the single most important
aspect of any moviemaking it's the
single most determining aspect of
whether the film will be any good it's
always the filmmaker
yes screenwriters matter of course they
matter but they're not the ultimate
architects of the film it really is the
director so that's kind of the
difference between novels and movies is
that you know you write a script it's
gonna go through a lot of filters a lot
of hands a lot of lenses often a lot of
writers usually the person who writes
the first draft of the script or the
first drafts often is not the person
that writes through the movie going into
production a lot of times there's
multiple writers so what I really would
like is to find a director that really
gets it and has a vision for how it
should be told as a film and is willing
to take creative license to really adapt
it well because a lot of times what
works in a book isn't going to work as
well on-screen and there's a lot of
world-building that gets opened up in
the second and third books and so some
of that might need to go into the first
movie so I'm just kind of looking at it
and I am open to adapting it myself but
I actually would prefer to have someone
else come in and do it because I think
it's very difficult for authors we're so
close to our material to have
perspective to really do a good job with
the screenplay I think it's better
sometimes to have someone with an
outside our set of eyes to come in and
really kind of shape the material so
yeah so we're kind of out to different
writers and directors I'm looking for
someone to come in and I just want that
meeting where it's like someone who has
the passion and the vision
and that's what I'm looking for I'm not
in a rush to do a deal with someone it
doesn't feel right so I just want to do
it in a way that feels good and where
we're gonna do something great that's
interesting that you that you actually
want to hand it off to someone else do
you think that from your prior working
that you saw too many people that were
close with great intentions and it
didn't turn out yes I think that that's
pretty accurate and even now even just
as a consumer when I go to see phones
there are certain books that have been
adapted by the authors and a lot of the
time I think they might have benefitted
from someone else coming in and I don't
know if that's a popular opinion or not
but gone girl is a good example I
actually think that that might have
benefitted from someone else really
working on that script I mean you can't
say it's all hypothetical but yeah
that's part of it and it's also like
from his spend time I would almost
rather spend time writing additional
books as opposed to working on a
screenplay where there's gonna be a lot
of notes a lot of changes and ultimately
I'm not the architect of it yeah and
it's also a little bit of you know I'm
not in a rush to get this done in a way
that doesn't feel right I've been in
development and I've seen it for so long
and it makes me more realistic about the
process like a lot of people think oh my
god I got an option deal or I got this
and like now I'm gonna be at the
premiere and like oh my gosh that does
not at all mean your movies gonna be
made and even if it is it could be so
long from now you know it's a long
process and also you're looking at a big
budget like that's the other thing that
happens with the kind of stuff that I'm
writing it can't be made for a low
budget right we're talking something 60
to 80 million at the minimum so that
requires a huge investment on someone's
part if you think about it so I'm just
much more realistic about the process
because of my experience jennifer any
advice to authors who are hoping to turn
their books into movies yeah I have
actually quite a few thoughts on that
what are my main thoughts is that
figuring out what is the appropriate way
to tell your book into a story so
sometimes it's going to be more
appropriate for film and as mentioned if
your book is not like a pretty sweeping
kind of tentpole sort of movie you're
have a hard time selling that to a major
movie studio right now based on the
types of material they're actually
making they're not really doing many
mid-range films anymore the conflict
side of that is if it could be made for
a very good price micro budget or a low
budget then you're gonna have probably
some options for film but I think TV is
really worth considering now and how it
would slot in in terms of how to
position it for that again you know
getting a good film agent film TV agent
to represent the rights is really
important and like I said I think having
a vision for what it's gonna be is it
like Star Wars is it like you know
something that's on TV stranger things
was a huge hit on Netflix is it
something like that like what is the way
that you position the material could
help with finding the right audience for
it and figuring out what it looks like
it's kind of the same as pitching it to
a publishing house like what is your
book like what kind of film will it make
so you have your literary agent but then
you're also looking for a film and
television yeah so that's a whole
process so I actually think I have I
think my four agents actually that
represent me right now and so um they
did all come through my book agent so
getting so if you have a book agent they
should be able to help you especially if
you've interest which in my case I did
I'd interest from producers so they
should be able to help set you up with a
film and TV agent and so I am at ICM
with Josie Friedman who's amazing and
who I had done deals with and seeing her
represent I see him as one of the best
book departments in the business they
were presenting a lot of huge authors so
I'm thrilled to be with her and to be
represented by them and so she handles
all the film TV aspect because it's all
highly specialized my book agent again
that's specialized what she does and
then the other agents I work with are
Curtis Brown who represent my UK rights
and my foreign translation rights so
we've actually sold china-russia
I believe so they kind of handled that
and that's also highly specialized so
yes getting set up with the right people
and I have some insider knowledge of
Hollywood but if you don't it is a very
tricky business in town to figure out to
know who's real who's not what's a good
fit what's not so you really do need a
good
and I believe that strongly another
option would be an entertainment
attorney who can often help do deals and
advise you in in so in a1 entertainment
attorney versus several agents good well
the agents all do different things so an
entertainment attorney would be in place
of having a film or TV agent or manager
you know you basically need someone who
can help you do the deals and you know
represent the material and potentially
even take it out on submission or take
it to the right people because it's like
the gatekeeper that gets you in the door
Hollywood you're gonna have a really
tough time getting much done if you
don't have someone that's an insider who
knows the world because it's a highly
specialized business so even if you have
a great attorney that's they've been
with your family for years but they have
no connections inside then I mean
someone like that might be able to
review a contract for you but again like
what goes in these deals is specific so
it's a specialized area of law so if
they don't really know what is the
industry standards and what are the
norms it might be hard for them I mean
they could probably advise you on you
know basic contract stuff but yeah I
think it's really important to have
someone that they do these kind of deals
and they understand them and I always
advise everyone like please have
representation before you sign anything
and that could be an attorney it could
be the author skilled but somebody needs
to look at your contracts because you
can get to a lot of trouble if you sign
you know a bad deal and a lot of
creative people do sometimes get taken
advantage of or do sometimes sign deals
that aren't in their best interest and
that doesn't just apply to writers
applies all across the business so I'm a
big believer in having good people on
your team that can advise you the nice
thing about agents is that they take a
percentage so you're not paying them
right off the bat so they're working
kind of I want to say it's for free but
it's like you're not paying anyone
everyone gets paid at the same time and
a good representative should earn their
percentage because they should get you a
better deal an attorney you're usually
going to be paying them more hourly so
you might be going out of pocket novel
structure versus screenplay structure
how are they different how are they the
same I mean I think that there's a lot
of similarities between them and when I
teach writing I ten
actually reference screenplay structure
the difference would be that screenplays
are much more rigid in terms of first
act which is usually the first 30 pages
are shut so second act midpoint and and
then how long a script can be like it is
much more rigid in terms of the way
they're structured where's it the book
you have more leeway the word count can
vary the page count can vary and then
exactly when you're hitting these big
moments can also vary novels can also
get away with being more episodic which
is to say you know one thing happens one
thing happens one thing happens it's not
always building whereas in a film you
can't really do that or if you do I
think your a lot of times in trouble
because it's not really building into
something that's a climax I mean most
films you're looking at 90 minutes to
hours really at the most I mean I know
some films go longer but usually it
doesn't work out well so I think you
just have a lot more leeway but that
said I really believe that that books
benefit from having a lot of the same
things in place so instead of like in
the first act moment I would call it
like the big thing that happens right
away or the inciting incident of a book
so that would really kind of be the end
of first act in a screenplay so we use a
little bit of a different terminology in
terms of what I would call it but yeah
like I said I think with novels you can
be a little more flexible but I tend to
think that having the same things climax
you know moral choice of a character and
then after the climax resolution I mean
those things are all the same for the
most part I mean stories are told a
certain way for a reason we talked about
relatability of a main character so do
mosun where i'm assuming most ye readers
are female do they want someone that's
the same as them a little bit above them
socially a little bit of below them you
know because if somebody's two above
someone we're gonna have a hard time
relating maybe even liking them it can
be I mean I I kind of think you know a
good writer can make you interested or
relate to anyone which is kind of
amazing generally though yes the
protagonist should be someone who's
relatable in some fashion and I think
you're going to see that
and why a with a protagonist is someone
who is you know somewhat like the reader
but I think that you can break away from
that and still write a successful book
that will work it doesn't always have to
be that way and whether or not a
character is likable you know I think
you always need to understand them I
mean there is some I think that if you
want to write an unlikable character you
are making your job a little bit harder
but it is possible I mean it's on a
white booklet gone girl which is an
example I talked about earlier the
characters are highly unlikable in my
mind but the book does work really well
so it is totally possible to do but
anytime you're doing that I think you
are making your work a little harder as
an author which can be a good challenge
but you know with a protagonist I think
you always want to dig in and kind of
try to find what is the thing that makes
some human what is the thing that makes
us understand them so if someone let's
say doesn't have teens but they want to
be a ye author and they're intrigued by
their own stories from when they were
younger how do they sort of tap into
what's going on today with that sort of
oh demographic that's an interesting
question
you know I we were talking about this in
my writing class and I think all of us
like can tap into what it was like to be
in high school and I think that while
the experience has changed somewhat it
hasn't changed so much that it's
unrelatable I think a lot of the same
things that we experience are still
going on social hierarchy you know the
different kind of stereotypes of what
kinds of people you're in school with
there is a whole thing about technology
and this is more applying to
contemporary young adult fiction it
doesn't apply so much to what I'm
writing but you know what is the new
technology are you going to date
yourself if you have that in your book
like if you're writing about Facebook
now is Facebook gonna be a thing that
only the parents are doing in five years
will your book feel dated my advice is
always to try not to put too much
identifying technology into a book
unless that is core to what the story is
to kind of try to think about or invent
a platform that maybe doesn't exist so
go a little bit in venting on that
because it won't date your book in the
same way another thing I see a lot of
why authors doing is doing period 80s
right because it's a time before cell
phones having cell phones changes
everything right you can find people
it's very hard to get lost if everyone
has cell phones so if you set it in the
80s and I see a lot of this now you kind
of eliminate all of that technology
another thing I also really highly
advise is not to have too much of your
book structured around texting or social
media or cell phones they try to keep it
more of a storytelling about characters
and those things are more ancillary
because what's at the core of a story
you know isn't really going to change a
lot and will still have an impact even
20 30 40 years from now whereas if your
book is all about Facebook then you know
that might not be relevant 40 years from
now we talked about some controversy in
the messages of some white novels
whether it's shaming of certain types of
stereotypes whether it's wanting the
quote strong female character which
sometimes has a negative connotation
because why should we make someone
strong in someone weak what can we talk
about some of the controversies and how
to work around well there have been a
lot of controversies and this is
something I feel strongly about and I
see it a lot we're about needing more
diversity and diversity of characters in
in all fiction not only young adult
fiction and so when I set out to write
my book it was really important to me
that my cast of characters be highly
diverse because when I look at things
like Hunger Games or divergent or any of
these and you can call up all the
billboards Twilight it's mostly white
characters you know and I think that to
me is not realistic not realistic for
the future but not realistic even for
now you know and I think it's really
incumbent on us as writers to really
feature characters from different
backgrounds and that look different ways
I do think having strong female
characters which is a really exciting
trope of why a is exciting the reason
why I think you see it so much in young
adult fiction is because women write
young adult fiction way more than men
it is a genre that's highly dominated by
female authors so I think that that's
why you see so many great strong women
characters in these books versus any
other
genres and that's also why the films
then end up because you know Hollywood
makes very few films that start women I
would say almost all the ones that they
do make these days are adapted from
books that were written by women so that
can be anything from gone girl to Hunger
Games to divergent
any of these and that's why so that's
again why I think it's really important
to see that diversity and that
sensitivity we talk about the moral
implications of what someone writes even
though someone may want to write and
show a protagonist and the correct light
quote unquote there's still stories with
of let's take the Diary of a teenage
girl which was a novel by Phoebe
Glockner and although there are things
in the in the book and in the film that
are not maybe what every parent would
want their daughter to be doing it's
very character it's very true of a
teenage girl especially in that time
period was like the 70s or whatever Bay
Area so totally different world so can
we talk about writing with that hanging
over your head but also wanting to keep
true to what's going on in either the
world now or that world yeah I mean I
think yeah I think it's really important
to be authentic and I think even at the
risk of being controversial I'm a big
believer in that and I think you know if
you're trying to you know do something
for a reason because you're worried
about it you know violating someone
else's moral standards I think that
you're probably not in a great place
with what you're writing I think you're
really you know adhering to truth and
authenticity is really important that
doesn't mean that you have to go so dark
or so into something but you know there
are a lot of kids we just remember teens
deal with a lot of really serious things
they deal with drugs I deal with suicide
they deal with sex they deal with all
these things to ignore that I think does
a disservice now that said like I don't
think you know if your book really isn't
about that like you know my books are
kind of these big adventure science
fiction books like if I started to throw
in like a drug youth plot line that
wasn't applicable to my world it would
feel forced so I think you know it just
really depends on what your narrative is
about because I also don't like tacking
on of like oh here's a random gay
character let me just put them in
because that you know it's like I don't
like it when it feels like Forester
Tower
tacked-on but it is possible my best
friend from high school is Robin Talley
and she writes queer why a fiction that
is what she does she's amazing at it all
of her books do you feature clear
characters and I love reading them and I
think it's really important because part
of why she writes them is because if
they had been around when we were in
high school it might have changed her
life
so I think it's really really important
to have that diversity in the genre I
was reading something on a CNN just
quickly doing research for our interview
and it was just the evolution of why a
and you know how the 80s was one thing
and then the 90s you know and then of
course now we've lived through Columbine
9/11 and now teen pregnancy drug abuse
bullying all that is is all much more
prevalent than maybe Judy Blume's era
yeah and so incorporating that and
making it more adult has been I guess a
struggle and sort of walking that fine
line how much is too adult which may
turn off some parents and how much is
not enough that'll turn off the
readership yeah I mean I think I mean
from what I know and from I know other
authors are writing I think they are
tackling all of these things and I don't
think they're holding back from dealing
with them in all their implications and
I think that that is fantastic I think
the nice thing when you write things
like what I do which is sci-fi and
fantasy is using more allegorical
approach to explore these issues so for
example in one of my colonies they do
have arranged marriage moral assets my
military society where they're basically
told who their betrothed to and then
sent to a clinic where they're supposed
to procreate and so right so that's like
but is a way to look at like what are
the implications of you know arranged
marriage where the implications of sex
and this is in a different world and so
it exists in my book and so maybe that
brings up some interesting questions so
it makes you think about kind of the way
our society is arranged so that's the
nice thing about writing science fiction
is you can kind of look at it from a
different angle
that said in terms of parents and
censorship you know I just tend not to
worry so much about that and I think a
lot of authors really kind of don't I
mean maybe there are some and I have
seamless like clean Wyatt
around where there's no cussing or sex
or anything boring pretty sophisticated
these days and like they're getting the
content no matter what right we just
between what's on the internet what's on
television so you know in my mind I'd
rather them even just be reading it you
know and I think most authors I know are
writing stories to be responsible and to
communicate something about experiences
you know and let's just say you are a
team that like my friends book who had a
parent who did commit suicide and here's
a book that is detailing that kind of
experience like wouldn't you want to
have that available to read it makes me
you know to make you feel less alone or
like my friend Robin who writes books
with featuring gay characters like wow
isn't that much more relatable if you're
in high school struggling with your
identity and struggling with trying to
tell your friends and family like and
then you read something that makes you
feel less alone in the world so I think
that's really important
yeah just driving around la you could
see any number of bus bench ads where we
won't mention the name of the company
but yeah they're quite risque and you
see that that is just part of the
culture now you know and has been I
think maybe it was more censored at a
certain point in time but I mean like
any bad word believe me a teenager has
heard it and probably might be using it
like I mean to think that they live in a
bubble where they're not exposed to
things I think is a fallacy I mean
obviously within a certain age range but
yeah and if they're not hearing it from
TV they're hearing it at school and I
don't think it's that possible to
control all of that so you know I think
a lot of it is just teaching about you
know responsibility and about you know
the proper context for things but you
know yeah I don't see it as an issue
with why I think it's great that they're
tackling so many hard-hitting issues
have you ever had a reader approach you
and was excited or curious about a
certain part of the book where you were
really or or the story that you were
really surprised that they picked up on
that and so it changed something in you
and how you approached the next part of
a chapter because you were surprised at
how much they really focused on
something that you thought maybe was
just glossed over yeah I mean and there
have been a few things
one of them was that there's a point of
view I continue in the underwater colony
through the subsequent two books where I
talk certain characters and there are
some what I would call minor supporting
characters that had a big impact where
people like oh I love mud I wish I hope
she continues I hope she comes back and
she was a relatively small character in
the first book so it was kind of
gratifying when somebody picks up on
something and you're like oh good
because I have a lot planned and a lot
is gonna happen with that character I'm
glad that you liked them there's a
character who is in the second book who
and won't reveal too much about but her
name's seeker and she comes from maybe
one of the other colonies but she I
wrote her in a way where I was like god
I don't know if she's gonna work as a
character I really hope people like her
because she's a little bit devolved a
little bit kind of golem ish like from
Lord of the Rings but I have some early
bloggers that are looking at the book
and one of them was mentioned how much
she likes seeker so go ahead I hope her
characters working because um she was
for me a challenge she's a character who
also presents as an antagonist to start
with cuz I was like I hope that this
whole arc will work with her because
she's really important in the same way
column is super important in the Lord of
the Rings and it wouldn't work without
him so anyway so it is kind of nice when
certain characters connect or certain
things that you wrote at work do you
envision the the readers while you're
writing or are you so in a world that
it's not even part of I mean are you
picturing someone reading this and their
reactions I'm just curious how close do
you really I mean I think when you're
writing books and you want to publish
you are like having this big kind of
dream like oh I so hope that I have
readers but it's not like someone's
specific that I picture and you know
when you're in a story I'm just really
in the story so I'm really not thinking
about a lot else I'm really get pretty
absorbed into just the story of my book
it's kind of like being reading a book
but then it's like choose your an
adventure or where you get to like you
know create where it goes so yeah so I'm
pretty much absorbed when I'm in that
and then I try not to think about it
because you know I just try to keep a
really kind of gratitude perspective and
I'm just grateful for anyone who reads
and loves the book like it's so great
anyone who comes to reading I just think
it's so fabulous and
care who they are where they came from
you know and I always try to talk to
them and like have a relationship
because you know I just always try to
channel myself as a young reader a young
fan of films fan of music and whenever
I've gotten to meet one of my idols you
know and what that is like and I always
just try to keep in mind you know going
back home it's especially cool because
you know there's not a lot of people
come through Roanoke Virginia so you
know it's really cute especially also
when the kids when you're talking about
your book and a lot of times they don't
realize you're the author sometimes they
just think that you're you know talking
about the book or whatever there would
be this moment like oh my god you wrote
this and it's like this big deal so I
just try to keep that in mind
lastly top five books a beginning why a
writer should read Wow
to tour to develop themselves yeah sure
gosh there's so much great stuff that
had a huge impact on me and it really
kind of will depend on what your genre
you want to write I'm trying to think
while John Green I think you have to
read The Fault in Our Stars or I mean he
has a lot of other great books he writes
so well his voice is really incredible
thing could be haven't read Harry Potter
please go read Harry Potter and I'm
jealous because I wish I hadn't read it
I could read it for the first time again
you know I think you know Hunger Games
the first book is absolutely worth
reading I love a book called
Daughter of Smoke and bone by Laini
Taylor although I didn't love the
subsequent books in the series the first
book is fabulous
there's an author named Leigh bardugo
who I love to death she's based in LA
and she wrote shadow and bone in a whole
series with those and then she has a new
book series out first 1/6 of crows and
it did hit number one on the New York
Times bestseller list
my other favorite author rating right
now is a probably Victoria Schwab she
also writes under the name ve Schwab and
she has an adult fantasy series called a
darker shade of magic but she also
writes y.a which is where she started
and her new one this savage song is next
on my to read list so she's a great
writer
what about blogs or you know magazines
that cater to why authors in terms of
support how to
yeah I mean there's a lot why a book
central which is run by CJ Redwine who
also is a New Times best selling ye
author she's fabulous
her new books Red Queen I believe it's
called is a great place there's a ton of
bloggers who specialize in why a and a
lot of us you know we'll get reviewed by
them I do have a blog tour going live
for my book that publishes so you can
just look up there's so many great blogs
and in terms of writing resources for
teen writers I believe there's something
called Figment which is a pretty cool
publication and has writing advice
online but the things that apply to yaa
apply to all fiction so I mean there's
just tons of good places to read I love
Neil Gaiman 'he's website and writing
and blog and yeah he's more known for
his adult stuff but he's written comic
books and he writes children's books
like Coraline and they're fabulous so
you know I think you can learn from all
of them Stephen King was an adult writer
his book on writing a lot of people
consider him the best young adult author
that is not actually a young adult
author there's a reason my teenagers
love his books so much he writes a lot
about kids and teens there are a lot of
times the protagonists so can't go wrong
with him